le shit de françois fillon les chansons
de nadine morano les lapsus les
dérapages de nos politiques se
multiplient ces derniers temps
est ce parce qu'on est en campagne celui
style trop de pression les réponses
d'olivier poncelet j'aime j'aime pas
renault tous coupables sauf carlos ghosn
j'aime renaud sur certaines chansons
le fait que le premier minus première
catégorie de glissement de langage chez
les politiques
l'approximation la petite erreur qui
fait rire tout le monde bien plus que
n'importe quel libre au titre écorché
sans doute zadig et voltaire
et puis il y a les dérapages très
contrôlée dirai quand je serai candidate
les candidats ont beau jouer les
candides de voltaire certains mots
s'échappe comme par hasard au bon
endroit et au bon moment pas comme ça se
faire avoir ou pas en moyenne nous
commettons à lapsus tous les 900 mots on
se dit que face aux caméras la boulette
sémantique n'en est que plus humaine
elle est liée à la pression aux 13 qui
met notre cerveau en ébullition et nous
fait dire l'exact contraire de ce que
l'on pense
houle inverse au fond ma détermination
n'a rien changé
mais si on veut battre la gauche avec la
droite
d'après ce psychanalyste c'est cette
pression médiatique entre autres qui
explique que les lapsus politique
remplissent les étagères de nos placards
archives mail à la personne à l'épreuve
ça met la personne si les imaginait que
vous compression du gaz comme vous
compressé du gaz au bout d'un moment il
n'y a pas 36 solutions
où ça explose où il ya une fuite un
homme politique sur le b
c'est un peu ce qui se passe dernière
fils de gaz en date si l'on peut dire
le lapsus de françois fillon
d'exploration et d'exploitation de
gisements de gaz de shit de schiste et
puis il ya les lapsus à connotation
sexuelle qui sont depuis longtemps le
bonheur des bêtisiers
le sexe ce qu'il ya de plus profond dans
l'homme dans la femme
nous avons aussi décidé de baisers de
baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés excusez
moi avec une inflation quasi nulle
donc pourquoi pas c'est un gots un code
qui finalement qui sera un code des
bonnes pratiques c'est la personne fait
ce lapsus d'une manière j'avais pas
permanente mais souvent dire on parade
idée fixe donc c'est plus vraiment à
lapsus
les lapsus par là notre inconscient
individuels et collectifs et en la
matière deux guerres mondiales avec
l'allemagne à propos de l'alsace et de
la lorraine
ça laisse des traces c'est totalement
incompréhensible et je le dis pas
simplement cher philippe richert parce
que je suis un no man en un je suis en
alsace
mais même les lapsus les plus graves
peuvent se rattraper avec un peu
d'autodérision
c'est là où vous voyez que j'ai raison
de m'investir dans le chantier de la
dépendance